>> Laura: WE SAY THIS A LOT
BUT DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY
JUDICIAL WATCH THEY CONFIRM
COLLUSION BETWEEN MUELLER AND
COMEY.
IN THE EMAILS, FBI OFFICIALS
ADVISED FORMER DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY TO CONSULT WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER BEFORE
COMEY TESTIFIED TO CONGRESS.
WHAT?
THAT SUBSTANTIATES NEWS REPORTS
THAT COMEY MET WITH MUELLER
PRIOR TO HIS TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE SENATE INTEL COMMITTEE IN
JUNE OF LAST YEAR.
JOHNNY IS NOT WITH MORE ON THIS,
IS TOM FENTON, THE PRESIDENT OF
JUDICIAL WATCH.
WE ARE ALSO JOINED BY WHITEWATER
DEPUTY INDEPENDENT COUNSEL SAUL
WALSENBURG ALONG WITH THE RNC
COMMITTEE WOMAN FROM CALIFORNIA
PRACTICING ATTORNEY.
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
TOM, IT'S TOUGH TO GET DOCUMENTS
OUT OF THIS JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND YOU HAD TO FILE HOW MANY
SUITS TO GET THIS NUGGET ABOUT
COMEY AND MUELLER?
>> TWO FEDERAL LOSSES, FREEDOM
OF INFORMATION ACT LAWSUITS.
WE BEGAN ASKING FOR DOCUMENTS IN
AUGUST OF LAST YEAR.
15 OR SO PAGES AND LAST WEEK OR
SO.
THEY SHALL COME AS YOU SAY,
JAMES COMEY WAS FIRED BY THE
PRESIDENT AND WITHIN A DAY OR
SO, HE'S COMING GETTING WITH THE
FBI ABOUT UPCOMING TESTIMONY
BECAUSE ALL OF CONGRESS WANTED
HIM TO TESTIFY.
YOU SEE THE EMAIL.
DEAR JIM.
HI, JIM.
CAN RECORDING IT, WHAT
INFORMATION DO YOU NEED ME TO
HAVE?
>> Laura: WE HAVE A COUPLE
FULL SCREENS OF THE EMAILS.
DIRECTOR, AND RESPONSE YOUR
EMAIL BELOW WE'VE CONSULTED WITH
CONSECUTIVE MANAGEMENT HERE
INCLUDING THE GENERAL COUNSEL
AND RECOMMEND THE FOLLOWING.
THERE IS MISTAKES.
THERE'S TYPOS.
CONSULT WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
MUELLER TO DETERMINE THE TIMING
OF ANY SUCH TRUST MONEY.
SO THE TIME HE SHOULD BE WORKED
OUT WITH MUELLER.
IS THERE ANY BENIGN EXPLANATION
FOR THIS?
>> TYPICALLY THERE WOULD BE SOME
COORDINATION, BUT WHAT COMEY
SAID WAS BEYOND THE PALE IN
TERMS OF WHAT GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS ARE TYPICALLY ALLOWED
TO SAY IN SUCH SITUATIONS.
CERTAINLY IF YOU ARE AN FBI
DIRECTOR AND YOU ARE HAVING
MEETINGS WITH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, TYPICALLY THE
AGENCY TALLIES YOU YOU'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO TALK ABOUT.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK ABOUT
DOCUMENTS YOU CREATED AT THE FBI
ABOUT THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
COMEY HAD FREE REIN DURING HIS
TESTIMONY AND IT WAS BLESSED
BOTH BY THE FBI IT LOOKS LIKE
AND BY MR. MUELLER.
>> Laura: SOL, THIS IS
CURIOUS.
AS THEY REFER TO AN EMAIL, I
GUESS THERE ARE INSTITUTIONAL
PRIVILEGES OR PREROGATIVES THAT
MAY BE PRESENTED BY ANY SUCH
TESTIMONY.
SO THE FBI, SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
OFFICE, MET WITH JAMES COMEY.
WE WANT TO BASICALLY CORDON
EIGHT ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS.
I GUESS, I DON'T KNOW THE
INSTITUTIONAL PRIVILEGES, THINGS
THAT COMEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO
REVEAL PRESUMABLY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
DO YOU SEE ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THIS, THE APPEARANCE OF
COORDINATION?
>> I DON'T SEE ANY PROBLEM FOR
MUELLER.
TO ME, THIS ISN'T REALLY NEW
NEWS.
I THINK COMEY AT THE TIME
ANNOUNCED HE WAS GOING TO
CONSULT WITH MUELLER.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT COMEY HAS
HAD A MAN CRUSH ON MUELLER FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AND WANTS WRAP
HIMSELF IN MUELLER'S GLORY.
I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY READ THESE
LATEST EMAILS THAT TOM GOT.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
WRONG WITH COMEY GOING TO
MUELLER AND SAYING I'M GOING TO
TESTIFY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS WITH
WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY OR HOW I'M
GOING TO SAY IT?
DO WE KNOW THAT MUELLER BLESSED
ANYTHING, OR IS THAT JUST
SOMEBODY SURMISED?
AGAIN, NOTHING SURPRISES ME
ABOUT JAMES COMEY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S BE USED FOR
SMEAR MUELLER.
>> Laura: HERE'S ANOTHER BIG
STORY.
HER ME TO COME I WANT TO GET
INTO THIS.
DEVIN NUNES AND TREY GOWDY WENT
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TODAY
AND THEY WERE ALLOWED TO REVIEW
CERTAIN CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THEY SAID THIS AFTERWARD.
WE HAD A PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION
TODAY WITH OFFICIALS AT THE
OFFICE OF DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE, DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, FBI AND RUTH QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THE INTEL COMMUNITY.
COMMITTED TO HOLDING FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF THESE MATTERS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DIALOGUE.
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
THIS FOLLOWS NEWNESS THREATENING
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS AGAINST
JEFF SESSIONS.
THREATENING CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS
TO GET ANYWHERE.
WHAT, WHERE IS THIS GOING?
>> LOOKS BAD FOR THE REPUTATION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI HERE.
IT TAKES THREATS, REPEATED
THREATS.
IT'S LIKE THOSE MOVIES WHERE THE
VILLAINS ARE CHASING THE TRAIN
AND THEY ARE THROWING STUFF OFF
THE BACK TO TRY TO DELAY THEM.
IT'S LIKE THAT.
BUT EVENTUALLY THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY THE PIPER AND
CONFORMED WITH INFORMATION.
THEY ARE DOING IT VERY SLOWLY.
CLEARLY SOMETHING THEY HAVE TO
HIDE BECAUSE IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE
SUMMING TO HARD TO KNOW IT'S
REALLY IRONIC HERE IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS AN
INFERIOR BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
CREATED BY CONGRESS.
FOR THEM TO ARROGANTLY SAY THAT
THEY ARE SOMEHOW ABOVE THEIR
CONGRESS AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER REQUESTS LIKE THE REST OF
THE GOVERNMENT IT'S REALLY
OUTRAGEOUS.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS THEM TO
COOPERATE.
THEY PUT OUT THE STORY THE DOJ
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS ON BOARD
WITH WHAT THEY'RE DOING BUT THEN
THE WHITE HOUSE BUT NOT AS DIM
AS I KNOW ACTUALLY WANT YOU TO
COOPERATE.
JUST DON'T GIVE THEM THIS EXTRA
TOP HIGH SECRET.
WE HAVE SEEN FROM THE REDACTIONS
IN THE PAST THAT HAVE BEEN
GRUDGINGLY UNVEILED AND THAT
THEY WERE ENOUGH IN BURGER.
THEY WERE SIMPLY THERE TO
PROTECT THE DUE DATE.
>> Laura: THEY WERE
EXCULPATORY.
THEY WERE EXCULPATORY.
NOT FOR THE DOJ.
>> FOR FLYNN AND OTHER PEOPLE.
THEY ARE PROTECTING.
>> Laura: THERE IS ALWAYS A
TUG-OF-WAR BETWEEN CONGRESS AND
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
THAT HAS ALWAYS EXISTED.
>> KNOCKED TWO THIS DEGREE.
>> Laura: THIS TAKES IT TO AN
NEW LEVEL.
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL HAS AN
INTERESTING ANALYSIS TO MAKE
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
SHE WRITES IT'S ABOUT THE FBI
SOURCE.
SHE SAYS WE KNOW MR. NUNEZ'S
REQUEST DEALS WITH THE TOP
SECRET INTEL SOURCE OF THE
FBI AND CIA WHO IS A U.S.
CITIZEN AND WHO WAS INVOLVED IN
THE RUSSIA COLLUSION PROBE.
WE MIGHT TAKE THIS TO MEAN THAT
THE FBI SECRETLY HAD A PERSON ON
THE PAYROLL WHO USED HIS OR HER
NONFBI CREDENTIALS TO INTERACT
IN SOME CAPACITY WITH THE TERM
CAMPAIGN.
STRESSFUL HAS INCREDIBLE
SOURCES, I KNOW THAT.
SHE SEEMS TO BE INDICATING THAT
THERE COULD'VE BEEN SOMEONE
INSIDE THE TERM CAMPAIGN FROM
THE FBI WHO WAS EMBEDDED IN
THERE.
I GUESS SPYING ON THE TERM
CAMPAIGN.
WE WILL SEE IF ANY OF THIS PANS
OUT BUT TOM.
FROM THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE THAT THERE WAS A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE OPERATION
AGAINST FLYNN WHILE HE WAS ON
THE CAMPAIGN ARE WORKING FOR THE
TRANSITION.
>> Laura: HOW DOES THAT PLAY
OUT?
WIRETAPS OR WHAT?
>> WHAT DID THE PROGRAM ENTAIL?
THIS JUSTICE BERMAN TAKES THE
APPROACH OF THE MODIFIED LIMITED
HANGOUT IN TERMS OF INFORMATION.
FOUR MONTHS THE MUELLER
OPERATION SAT ON THE FACT THAT
THEY HAD THE STRZOK-PAGE
MESSAGES.
THEN WE FOUND OUT ABOUT THE
CLINTON DNC DOSSIER.
THERE IS GOING TO A THIRD OR
FIFTH SHOE THAT DROPS.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AT ISSUE
HERE.
THERE IS EMBARRASSING
INFORMATION.
>> Laura: SOL, THE STRASSEL
POINTS.
I KNOW YOU LOVE IFS.
IF THE FBI EMBEDDED SOMEONE
INSIDE THE TERM CAMPAIGN WITH A
BELIEF OR RELIGION OR PURPOSE,
IF RESTER WAS REALLY TRYING TO
THROW THE ELECTION IF THEY IT
INFORMATION INDICATING THAT,
THEY PUT SOMEONE INSIDE THE TERM
CAMPAIGN BURROWED AWAY LOOKING
IN ONE OF THOSE CUBICLES,
WITH HIS YOU'RE OUT OR HER EAR
OUT, WHAT'S THE PROBLEM THERE IF
THERE'S A PROBLEM THERE?
>> BO, THERE'S A BIG PROBLEM
UNLESS YOU HAVE THE SAME KIND OF
PROBLEM YOU HAVE WHEN YOU SEARCH
A LAWYER'S OFFICE.
YOU BETTER HAVE SOME THING
REALLY, REALLY GOOD TO BE ABLE
TO JUSTIFY THAT.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THERE'S AN OLD SAYING.
BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER, LET'S
GIVE CREDIT TO JOHN EHRLICHMAN,
THE AUTHOR OF MODIFIED LIMITED
HANGOUT.
I WOULD WANT TO LEAVE HIM
TWISTING SLOWLY, SLOWLY AND THE
WIND FROM ALORA.
>> Laura: EXCELLENT.
>> KEEP IN MIND THERE'S AN OLD
SAYING THE WAGES OF CRYING WOLF.
HARMEET PUT HER FINGER ON IT.
WE'VE SEEN TOO MANY INSTANCES
WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IN THE API HAS SAID WE HAVE
TO REDACT THIS BECAUSE IT'S
ENDANGERING NATIONAL SECURITY
AND ITS CLASS BY.
WE'VE SEEN NO TIME AFTER TIME
WHERE IT'S BEEN UNREDACTED AND
IT'S JUST BEEN EMBARRASSING.
THE LATEST EXAMPLE -- WHEN YOU
DO THAT TWO OR THREE TIMES THE
FLOOR GOING TO STOP BELIEVING
IN.
YOU LOSE ALL CREDIT ABILITY.
WE SAW THAT LAST WEEKEND WHEN
THEY FINALLY UNREDACTED TO
PASSAGES IN THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MAJORITY
REPORT, THE SELECT COMMITTEE
REPORT, THEY REVEALED TWO
INCREDIBLE THINGS.
ONE THAT THE FBI DIDN'T THINK
MIKE FLYNN HAD LIED.
WE HEARD ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: HUGE.
>> SHOCKING.
THAT PEOPLE HAVEN'T FOCUSED ON
ENOUGH, THAT THE UNDERLYING
CRIME MIKE FLYNN WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED FOR WAS THE LOGAN
ACT, AN ACT THAT SPENT A DEAD
LETTER FOR OVER 200 YEARS.
ABSOLUTELY SHOCKING.
>> Laura: THEN JOHN KERRY
NEVER VIOLATED, OF COURSE.
>> IT'S REALLY SHOCKING.
IT'S REALLY SHOCKING THAT SALLY
YATES WOULD APPROVE AND GREEN
LIGHT AN INVESTIGATION OF
ANYBODY FOR VIOLATING THE LOGAN
ACT.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK TURKEY.
WE ARE WAY OVER.
SOUND.
THE HISSY FIT OF A RESIGNATION
LETTER.
OH, COME ON.
SHE MARCHES HERSELF OR THE
AGENTS TO INTERVIEW FLYNN.
THAT WHOLE THING SMELLS LIKE A
BIG FAT SET UP TO ME.
SALLY YATES.
HAVING ANY BUSINESS GOING TO
INTERVIEW MIKE FLYNN.
HE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A LAWYER.
OF COURSE I'LL TALK TO YOU.
MIKE FLYNN SHOULD'VE NEVER
TALKED TO THEM.
HE DIDN'T THINK ANYTHING OF IT.